u
le temps de nettoyer la portedÇt
quelques jours qu'il tente
des "Z" et sa photo,
tel un criminel. "Collaborateur,
À 69 ans, ce vétéran
de la personne en Russie pensait
que les années les plus somb
de son pays étaient derrière
lui. Mais il avait tort.
au totalitarisme tel que nous
l'avons vécu jeunes", OlOlOleg,
qui, comme membre du groupe
Memorial, s'est battu
Mais c'est à refaire.
sa porte, est beaucoup
plus qu'une lettre et dans
le contexte, elle donne froid
dans le dos. Devenue symbole
et de la propagande militaire,
elle sert désormais à intimider
ceux qui dénoncent publiquement
la guerre de Vladimir Poutine
en Ukraine. Et le cas d'Oleg
est loin d'être le seul.
Ce genre d'intimidation,
au fruit de la délation,
se multiplie. Tous les jou
le "Z" d d d d d d d d d d d d y
Ivanov, un étudiant engagéde l'.
Le graffiti, qui dit :
est apparu sur sa propre
avant le week-end et sur celle
de plusieurs de sentntntntntntnt
les auteomomomomomment
ils ont trouvé son adresse,
mais c'est terrifiant.
"Bien sûr, j'ai peur, dit-il.
Ces lois répressives nous
menacent de 15 ans de prison."
La plupart des affiches
portent d'ailleurs le numéro
des articles du code pén
prévoit des peines pour toute
des soldats russes.
Mais Oleg Orlov dit qu'il
ne se taira pas pour autant. "Hi
parce que j'ai honte de mon pays
et de mes concitoyens. Ils
se mettent la tête dans le sable
et ceux qui ne sont pas d'accord
avec la guerre ont peur d'ouvrir
la bouche."
Il y en a encore comme lui
qui osent manifester,
ne serait-ce que quelques
minutes pour dénoncer la
barbarie, mais c'est tolérance
zéro dans toute la Russie.
(chant de protestation)
Cet homme a été arrêté samedi
avec une simple pancarte qui
disait que les enfants méritentt
simplement plus aucune tribune
pour s'exprimer librement.
Même l'incontournable festival
du documentaire de Moscou
n'a pas échappé à cette nouvelle
censure, car seueueueueueueur,
le réalisateur Vitaly Mansky,
a été insulté, puis agressé
en public.
L'homme qui l'a aspergét t t t.
Secoué mais pas surpris,
il faut vaincre la peur,
kykykykykykyky sur le vif.s s s,
c'est à nous aussi de
se défendre. Il faut se sauver
nous-mêmes de cette tyrannie.
Il faut le faire pour nos
enfants, c'est plus vrai
et nécessaire que jamais."
Mais Oleg ne sait pasrarararars
pour retrouver une liberté
qu'il a déjà connue.
Et, selon lui, aucun autre pays
qui s'est libéré du
totalitarisme n'a replongé
dedans comme le fait la Russie
aujourd'hui. À quoi bon nettoyer
sa porte? Il sait que tôt
ou tard, ils reviendront